[Música]
el arquitecto de la guerra contra los
narcotraficantes en México durante
mediados del 2000 fue declarado culpable
Por recibir cuantiosos sobornos del
Cartel De Sinaloa a cambio de protección
y ayuda para enviar droga a Estados
Unidos hablamos de Genaro García Luna
director de la agencia Federal de
investigación de México de 2001 a 2005 y
secretario de seguridad pública de 2006
a 2012 en ese tiempo trabajo con las
agencias antinarcóticos y de
inteligencia de Estados Unidos en el
marco de la política contra los carteles
del expresidente Felipe Calderón la
conversación sobre este tema es con
nuestro segundo invitado del día Carlos
Pérez profesor investigador del centro
de investigación y docencia económicas
cide e integrante de la comisión de la
verdad de México un placer que nos
acompañe aquí en France 24 este caso de
García Luna habla de una estructura
dentro del estado mexicano para
favorecer a los carteles o solo es un
juicio individual contra el ex
secretario de seguridad
Hola Qué tal Cómo estás Mira sí se trata
en efecto de un juicio contra México
contra la estructura política de México
es también un juicio contra la relación
bilateral entre México y Estados Unidos
de la que Genaro Barcelona fue el
principal beneficiario y en general es
un juicio que habla sobre toda la
situación política de México para que el
público internacional tenga contexto
Genaro García Luna fue el policía
estrella en México del año 2000 al año
2012 más concretamente del año 2006 al
año 2012 se está juzgando a la persona
que dirigió ejecutó que operó la
política antidrogas de México en el
momento en que crece la violencia en el
año 2007 en adelante entonces en el
fondo se está juzgando toda la guerra
contra las drogas y toda la violencia
que ha recorrido México desde entonces
es un duro golpe insisto para el
gobierno mexicano para el Estado mexica
en su conjunto y duro golpe también para
la relación bilateral con los Estados
Unidos y como usted nos decía Genaro
García Luna tenía un
alto y es fundamental en todo este
arquetipo en la lucha contra el
narcotráfico Entonces en este juicio
varios exfiscales y también
narcotraficantes mencionaron al
expresidente Felipe Calderón con quien
García Luna trabajó y también al actual
mandatario Andrés Manuel López Obrador
explícanos Qué pasó con esas menciones
hay que señalar que durante el juicio
que se celebra en contra de generar
Barcelona Nueva York no solamente se
menciona su participación en la
conspiración de tráfico de cocaína de
México hacia Estados Unidos sino también
toca toda la estructura del estado es
decir esa se mencionó también la
responsabilidad del expresidente Felipe
Calderón pero también de gobernadores
también de alcaldes también de jefes
policiales también de jefes de aduana
habló de toda la estructura no la gran
pregunta que viene ahora y es quizás
donde más especulación hay hoy en México
es ya una vez siendo declarado culpable
Genaro García luna y una vez y se se
imponga la pena Esto va a suceder en
junio de este año cuánto más va a hablar
hasta ahora Genaro García Luna ha sido
muy silencioso ha sido muy precavido no
que en lo que señala él no declaró en el
juicio y ahora la pregunta es si ya una
vez que haya sido declarado culpable va
a testificar en contra de otros miembros
del estado y más en concreto sobre su ex
jefe Felipe Calderón entonces esa es la
discusión que se tiene hoy cuando
amanecemos en Ciudad de México y más
allá García Luna testifica o no en
contra de Calderón como usted ya lo ha
dicho esto es un caso que está
salpicando a todo el estado mexicano
teniendo esto en cuenta que tantas
opciones hay de que en Estados Unidos o
incluso en México se sigan procesando a
altos funcionarios por relaciones con
carteles sobre todo teniendo en cuenta
que el general Salvador Cienfuegos que
estaba detenido en Estados Unidos Fue
deportado a México por petición de este
país
bueno casi sin quererlo el juicio de
General Barcelona y lo que pasó con el
General Cienfuegos va a provocar varias
cosas en primer lugar es va a ser muy
poco probable que funcionarios mexicanos
sigan viajando a Disneylandia o Estados
Unidos cada tanto es decir Estados
Unidos va a dejar de ser un lugar
turístico para muchos funcionarios por
el temor de que vayan a ser arrestados
en cualquier momento Entonces eso va a
terminar se reducen también los
incentivos o se eliminan los incentivos
para extraditar criminales mexicanos
Estados Unidos que luego puedan como
testigos protegidos recordarán que en el
juicio contra García Luna prácticamente
toda la evidencia que se presentó fue
dicha por testigos protegidos por
criminales que luego tenían sentencias
más rígidas y hablaban en contra de
funcionarios públicos entonces cuesta
pensar que alguien más vaya extraditar
gente a Estados Unidos que luego pueda
hablar en contra de ellos o que alguien
vaya a tomar el teléfono de la DEA o de
las agencias estadounidenses en efecto
se se se va a haber muchos cambios y
entre otros están los cambios con
Estados Unidos seguramente hay hay menos
funcionarios que van a querer viajar al
norte de la frontera con México y como
usted lo mencionó este caso de García
Luna fue basado básicamente en
testimonios de capos narcotraficantes
principalmente cuatro y no hubo unas
pruebas más fehacientes que tuvieran
tanta fuerza como estos testimonios
estos testimonios y que sean por parte
de narcotraficantes le resta
credibilidad al juicio o no le resta
credibilidad al juicio había doce
personas independientes que terminan por
dar su veredicto y y hay que respetarlo
me parece que que es objetivo hay
quienes pensamos ya dicho eso hay
quienes pensamos que en el juicio se
pudo haber presentado mucha más
evidencia material es decir no hubo
fotografías luego grabaciones no hay
videos no hay cuentas Fiscales no no hay
nada material que sostenga lo que
dijeron los Testigos protegidos los
Testigos protegidos sin embargo sí dejan
digamos
evidencia eso está reconocido como como
evidencia en Estados Unidos son parte
fundamental en la lucha contra el crimen
organizado las evidencias que
proporcionan los Testigos pero algunos
que nos dedicamos a investigar el crimen
organizado en América Latina en México
en Estados Unidos si nos quedamos un
poco con mal sabor de boca por el hecho
de que no se presentó evidencia material
insisto grabaciones las fotos que según
mucha evidencia y según muchas personas
existen pues la pregunta que muchos nos
hacíamos hasta el domingo era por qué la
fiscalía no las presentó era para
proteger a las agencias estadounidenses
era porque luego iban a ser utilizadas
para juicios posteriores probablemente
contra el expresidente Felipe Calderón
sobre eso solo podemos especular Lo
cierto es que a largo plazo esto siempre
se termina Sabiendo y Carlos Le quiero
preguntar una cuestión más porque García
Luna era un Aliado del FBI y de la lucha
antinarcóticos que lideraba Estados
Unidos a pesar de esto cuéntenos Cómo se
pasó de esta Alianza al juicio en el que
hoy lo declaran culpable
Bueno eso es tremendo y lo dices bien y
lo dices de forma muy acertada y Genaro
García Luna tenía su oficina llena de
diplomas que le había dado el FBI que le
había dado la DEA era gran amigo de las
agencias estadounidenses en México la
pregunta es cuánto ellos sabían o no de
su contubernio con El Cártel de Sinaloa
mientras trabajaba en México el hecho
que cuando dejó de trabajar en México en
el año 2012 fue a Estados Unidos
construyó su propia empresa de
consultorías estableció en la Florida
continuó con estas relaciones y por eso
todo mundo nos sorprendió cuando hace
tres años es detenido en Estados Unidos
por la misma aldea esto nos habla entre
otras cosas de que hay muchos intereses
muchos incentivos y que la política
exterior antinarcóticos de Estados
Unidos no es monolítica sino
fragmentaria hay mucha gente que piensa
distinto diferentes intereses y sus
antiguos protectores no lo pudieron
seguir protegiendo ya después del año
Estados Unidos como se dice no tiene
amistades sino intereses y y el caso de
Genaro García Luna así lo demuestra tal
cual como usted lo está diciendo se
demostró el interés de Estados Unidos en
este caso Carlos Pérez investigador de
la comisión de la verdad de México
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros Le
agradezco mucho y que tenga un buen día
y ustedes no se vayan porque en segundos
volvemos con más noticias en France 24
[Música]